avertissement lancé aujourd'hui en marge
de la coop 25 à madrid les émissions de
co2 d'origine fossile ont continué à
croître en 2019
l'urgence climatique force les
investisseurs à s'engager de façon plus
responsable
quels sont les risques pour l'économie
l'environnement économique avec nomertin
coiteux économiste en chef de la caisse
de dépôt et placement du québec - martin
coiteux on sera à vous ancien ministre
on vous a beaucoup vu dans l'actualité
pendant des années comment allez vous je
vais très bien dans les trains c'est un
métier passionnant que celui
d'économiste en chef dans les faits moi
je suis retourné ce qu'était mes
anciennes amours oui mais dans une
superbe organisation qui fait que la
caisse de dépôt vous ennuie vous de la
politique
non honnêtement non pas du tout je n'ai
pas détesté ce que j'ai fait pendant
cette période là mais franchement j'aime
beaucoup ce que je peux m vous faites
quoi exactement comme économiste en chef
de la caisse de dépôt
vous faites du travail d'économistes
bien sûr dans quel objectif dans quel
but quand danger j'ai une équipe
vraiment superbe d'une vingtaine
d'économistes la majeure partie est à
montréal mais j'en ai qui sont aux
états-unis j'en ai qui sont en asie
également dans mon équipe et on forme
une vue qui est sûr les grands risques
dans l'économie mondiale ont fait des
scénarios sur l'économie mondiale ont
fait le suivi des banques centrales est
ce que ça peut impliquer évidemment sur
l'environnement d'investissement mais on
fait un scan du monde entier donc c'est
passionnant donc dans l'intérêt
d'investissement de la caisse de dépôt
la caisse regarde vos analyses
économiques essentiellement restées et
plus profondément dans l'intérêt des
déposants alors les déposera confie
déçoit marrakech et des décisions se
prennent en matière d'investissement de
répartition des actifs géographique par
classe d'actifs et les grandes tendances
de l'économie c'est une variable action
absolument essentiel qu'est ce qu'on
doit savoir qu'est ce qui est important
dans votre radar présentement beaucoup
de choses si on regarde le long terme
vous avez ouvert vous avez ouvert la
discussion sur les changements
climatiques c'est clair que ça va être
un enjeu majeur
ce point dangereux conjoncturel c'est un
enjeu qui va nous accompagner longtemps
si on regarde la conjoncture est
essentielle mais je pense que ce qui est
le plus important est ce que les états
unis la chine vont trouver un terrain
d'entente
je pense très important pour les
perspectives 2020 et en particulier les
banques centrales ont donné un coup de
pouce récemment parce qu'elles ont
elles sont presque toutes passées en
mode assouplissement des politiques
monétaires donc les perspectives de
trêve commercial et je pars de 13 ans je
pense pas que ça règle le problème entre
les états unis la chine et
l'assouplissement monétaire qu'on
observe un peu partout sur la planète
conjoncturellement c'est de bonne augure
est-ce que vous avez l'impression à
chaque jour que l'avenir des tensions
commerciales et d'un accord commercial
se joue à peu près chaque jour que la
tendance n'est pas précise l'étude il
peut y avoir une trêve commercial qui
serait positive pour l'économie mondiale
en 2020 mais il faudrait pas suffisant
il faudra pas être naïf et croire que ça
va régler le problème de la rivalité
entre la chine et les états unis
à plus long terme ce qui se passe est
une rivalité technologique
c'est une réalité géopolitique tout
court et dans le fond ce que ça remet en
question et ça c'est fondamental
si le modèle de mondialisation
économique qu'on a connus depuis même
avant l'entrée de la chine au sein de
l'om s'est donc d'un monde beaucoup plus
protectionniste elles montrent plus
protectionniste un monde
moi j'appelle ça la vie furent qu'à sion
en deux mondes alors il ya des standards
technologiques qui vont être plus près
des développements technologiques des
entreprises chinoises et je pense que
d'un autre côté ça va être l'occident
les etats-unis l'europe qui vont avoir
des standards un peu différent et ça ça
change de roulement la donne pour le
futur dont le dire quoi des standards ça
veut dire par exemple dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
domaine du 5 gss qu'on peut penser à ce
qu'il ya une convergence des standards
comme on aurait pu le penser à l'époque
de la grande mondialisation d'économie
où tout le monde faisait finalement
ensemble les mêmes choses avec les mêmes
standards
je pense que dans l'environnement qui
s'en vient sera pas le cas la rivalité
technologique va impliquer un certain
nombre de coupures est donc plus de plus
de régionalisation et moins de
mondialisation est ce qu'il ya un danger
à voir les assouplissements des banques
centrales que ce soit des baisses de
taux d'intérêt des taux négatifs même à
certains endroits des liquidités
supplémentaires est ce qu'on est dedans
je danse la ration problème actuel c'est
la difficulté que toutes les banques
centrales ont de normaliser leur
politique monétaire on a parlé de
l'assouplissement dans lequel on se
trouve aujourd'hui ça aide l'économie à
court terme
mais il faudrait qu'un jour on puisse
retourner des taux d'intérêts normaux
mais on n'est pas là on n'est pas le dos
à manches pas de seins pour plusieurs
raisons et je pense que l'une des
raisons principales
et on l'a vu avec la tentative de la
réserve fédérale de normaliser ses taux
c'est l'ampleur de l'endettement
aujourd'hui je tente pas seulement et
surtout pas seulement d'endettement
public je parle de l'endettement privé
le niveau des têtes dans l'économie
mondiale des ménages d'être des sociétés
est très élevé et conséquemment les
banques centrales sont pratiquement
obligé de livrer à l'économie des taux
d'intérêt faibles sans ses taux
d'intérêt la on aurait du mal à
connaître les taux de croissance qu'on a
actuellement et ça va se poursuivre
c'est une espèce de situations
j'appellerai peut-être pas ça une trappe
de taux d'intérêt faibles mais il ya des
façons de s'en sortir
et honnêtement la meilleure façon de
s'en sortir c'est d'abord de la
croissance économique soutenable à long
terme la croissance durable la
croissance inclusive
on y revient donc il faut vraiment faire
les investissements pour l'avenir c'est
pas seulement question de taux d'intérêt
c'est une question d'investissement dans
le potentiel de l'économie ce soit qui
va nous nous permettre éventuellement de
pouvoir amener des taux d'intérêts
normaux où placez-vous la crise
climatique dans sa commun vous analysez
ça comment les grands investisseurs
doivent réagir d'avancé c'est l'enjeu de
notre temps le sien en a un qu'on doit
qu'on doit considérer comme étant
l'enjeu le plus important c'est vraiment
celui ci ce n'est pas qu'un enjeu
économique c'est un enjeu de conditions
d'existence sur la planète terre disons
les choses telles qu'elles sont il faut
attaquer ce problème très rapidement il
faut le faire de façon décisive alors
les investisseurs ont un rôle à jouer
les investisseurs d'abord peuvent
choisir dans quel actif qui vont mettre
leurs billes alors nous on a décidé
qu'on a on mettrait moins dans des
actifs qui sont intenses en carbone on a
des objectifs de réduction de notre
empreinte carbone
on a des objectifs d'augmenter nos
investissements notamment dans les
énergies renouvelables et je dirais
aussi se travailler avec des partenaires
donc avec d'autres investisseurs c'est
de pousser l'ensemble la société en
faire davantage les entreprises à être
plus transparents sur leurs stratégies
d'investissement sur leur modèle
d'affaires
quel est le risque climatique qui
s'applique à elle et quelles sont leurs
stratégies finalement pour n'ont pas
augmenté les risques climatiques nos
contraire
les réduire et c'est là qu'il faut
investir dans le futur martin coiteux
vous êtes maintenant économiste en chef
de la caisse de dépôt au plaisir de se
retrouver
merci mes grands plaisirs mais sûrement